public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
michel sociaux et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec
les échos avec radio classique et avec
la fp représenter ce soir par nos deux
confrères ici présents paulo bria et
augustin lefebvre messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir trois grandes questions pour
vous bruno retailleau un faut-il
renforcer les mesures antiterroristes
qu'est ce que vous préconisez 2 quelle
opposition défendez-vous face à emmanuel
macron qui entend poursuivre les
réformes certaines d'ailleurs préconisée
par la droite enfin 3 les républicains
ont-ils une ligne sur l'europe forces
républicaines que vous présidez a tenu
samedi une convention sur un sujet qui
divise votre camp et vous avez d'ores et
déjà des propositions a dévoilé ce soir
sur ce plateau
l'hommage cérémonie donc mercredi aux
invalides à la mémoire du lieutenant
colonel arnaud beltrame qui a consenti
le sacrifice ultime
mais aussi les questions et les
propositions de l'opposition qui intente
aujourd'hui un procès au pouvoir un
procès en à éviter c'est la première
partie de l'épreuve de vérité
[Musique]
avec cette question posée par paul briat
bonsoir bruno retailleau après les
attentats de carcassonne et de trèbes en
fin de semaine dernière commis par un
ficher s est ce que il faut renforcer
les mesures antiterroristes
sans doute faut-il les renforcer il faut
jamais s'interdire de mieux faire pour
pouvoir protéger les français simplement
ce que je veux dire puisque c'est ma
première émission je veux moi aussi
rendre hommage aux forces de l'ordre
bien sûr les services de renseignement
les policiers la gendarmerie et bien sûr
je veux m'incliner devant la mémoire de
cet officier français du colonel arnaud
beltrame qui a fait un geste absolument
magnifique qu'il a offert sa vie pour
que d'autres vies soient sauvés il a
réaffirmé nos valeurs savez c'est
terrorisme divise parce qu'il considère
qu' on est le ventre mou de l'occident
c'est le théoricien du jihad global
monsieur abou moussab al souris qui dans
les années 2000 2005 2006 avait théorisé
le jihad global
et ces gens-là nous visent pour ce que
nous sommes pour les valeurs parce
qu'ils prétendent que l'on croit plus en
rien qu'on est dans une société
consumériste et c est que fait le
colonel un nouvelle trame
il réaffirme que la pointe de notre
civilisation
c'est le respect de la vie jusqu'à
offrir sa vie pour en sauver une autre
il réaffirme que justement on a des
valeurs qui sont des valeurs très fortes
et en quelque sorte
il montre le chemin de la résistance qui
la réaffirmation de nos valeurs alors je
vous réponds précisément sur les mesures
dites est ce qu'il faut des mesures ce
que moi d'abord je veux vous dire c'est
que on a besoin sans doute de mesures
mais d'abord on a besoin de lucidité et
on a besoin de courage
la semaine dernière je reviens
rapidement sur deux faits qui m'ont
choqué j'ai réagi aux deux d'abord la
réponse de benjamin griveaux kyi et
porte-parole du gouvernement
mardi dernier à la tribune de 500
intellectuels qui dénonçait un
séparatisme islamistes
monsieur griveaux dit quoi le porte
parole du gouvernement
attention attention on stigmatise ça
signifie qu'il n'a rien compris au
phénomène du communautarisme
dimanche ce castaner patron d'ems marche
un des ministres les plus importants les
plus proches du président de la
république qui lui dit il n'y a pas de
problème on peut accueillir les
djihadistes qui ont été faits
prisonniers en irak y en a eu très peu
j'étais en irak ya un mois et demi il y
en a eu beaucoup plus en syrie progrès
coûte réactions montrent que nous
n'avons ils ont ni lucidité ni le
courage d'appliquer à mon sens des
mesures qui sont déjà dans le droit
français avant même de parler de
nouvelles mesures appliquons la dureté
de la loi vous avez cité monsieur
castaner on va l'écouter justement et
dire qu'il faut accueillir les revenants
du levant payer certains font de la
politique et disent il faut leur
interdire de revenir
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire notamment
les mères isolées avec des enfants elles
vont revenir quand même et dont je crois
qu'il vaut mieux les suivre les
accueillir les emprisonner chaque fois
que des actes délictuels ou criminels
ont été commis pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse identifier justement le risque
plutôt que de se contenter de dire on
aura interdiction formelle de revenir
dites vous bien que ces femmes ces
enfants 67 77 enfants de moins de 13 ans
sont concernés ils reviendront ils
reviendront vite il n'en vous dites il
faut qu'ils ne reviennent pas les
revenants les djihadistes qu'il soit
homme ou femme
il en est pas question j'étais et j'ai
questionné beaucoup quand je suis allé
en irak qui un mois et demi les
autorités irakiennes j'ai questionné
aussi les populations les minorités qui
ont été les victimes
je pense aux eyzies dit encore à l'heure
où je vous parle des milliers de femmes
de jeunes familles zidi qui servent
d'esclaves sexuels et bien les autorités
ou les minorités chrétiens d'orient
toutes m'ont dit non mais c'est à nous
de les juger et doivent rester dans nos
pays parce que c'est là qu'ils ont
commis les pires des atrocités alors moi
je parle pas des enfants
même si à mon ami c'est une bombe à
retardement pour certains un lionceau du
califat qui ont sans doute vu des images
atroces et qui sont sans doute marqué à
vie mais sur les djihadistes
il n'est pas question comme ou femmes
évidemment là vous donner raison là
ministre de la défense madame bâ rallye
après avait dit effectivement le mieux
c'est qu'il disparaisse vous savez en
irak
ils ont fait très peu de prisonniers moi
j'ai posé la question à l'époque avait
le cas de quelques femmes
j'ai jamais pu avoir de réponse sur le
nombre de djihadistes hommes il y en a
eu beaucoup plus parce que notamment en
syrie il ya eu les kurdes ont eux aussi
ont parlé du drame d'afrique on va en
parler oui mais qui ont été donc qui ont
fait prisonniers des djihadistes et il y
en a beaucoup plus en tout cas ce que je
veux dire c'est que il ya sans doute des
mesures à prendre je pense que la double
peine
elle est essentielle bonne soirée glam
et bien sûr d être en jeu qu'ils ont été
pour aider en feront bien sûr parce que
quand on accueille en est on sur
laquelle nicolas sarkozy était revenu un
bien sûr en 2003 pas comme président de
la république quand il était ministre de
l'intérieur je crois sur les
propositions de laurent wauquiez de se
mettre à laurent wauquiez propose
l'expulsion de tous les fichiers s est
rangée c'est l'une de ses propositions
il propose aussi de revenir à l'état
d'urgence ça vous paraît opportun comme
proposition fois je pense qu'on fait
déjà contesté y compris dans votre camp
oui je pense qu'on peut tout étudié
simplement moi je pense que 1
il faut que l'on puisse avoir ce
réarmement moral moi je pense que le
plus grave c'est la réaction
d'ailleurs je m'étonne pas ce que la
presse on a peu parlé et pourtant la
presse on a été victime
est-ce que vous avez vu quelle a été la
réaction dans le quartier de trèbes où
son talent et vos collègues journalistes
ou sont allés des forces de l'ordre vous
aurez été les journalistes n'étaient pas
bienvenus voilà ils ont été caillassés
et ça c'est terrible donc encore une
fois on peut étudier un certain nombre
de mesures mais alors soyons précis il
et quel est ce qu'il faut des mesures de
julie
non c'est tous les ans fin en tout cas
des leurs moi je propose que la double
peine soit rétablie et que dès qu'un
fichier s est un étranger donc qu'il a
commis un acte de délinquance parce
qu'il ya un continuum entre la
délinquance de droit commun et
aujourd'hui les actes de terrorisme peut
être danger est ce sont des marocains
bien sûr étonnant mais bien sûr et donc
tant qu'on n'est pas condamné évidemment
ce que je moi je propose c'est
clairement l'expulsion dès lors qu'il ya
la condamnation et que on a commis sur
le sol français lors des actes de
délinquance
on expulse l'on amélioré à merde ensuite
ensuite je pense que sur les frérots
salafisme notamment le salafisme
est-ce qu'il faut l'interdire le
salafisme mais on peut pas interdire le
salafisme en tant qu'idéologie parce que
vous n'interdisez pas une idéologie
simplement vous pouvez en interdire la
fois les manifestations et les
mouvements exactement manuel valls il a
été enlevé guilad parler de salafisme et
je pense que pourquoi est-ce-que à
martial il ya plusieurs mosquées
salafistes
il ya des dizaines de mosquées
salafistes en france qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour les fermer le trop de notre
droit actuel c'est ce que je veux dire
l'idée que je veux faire passer c'est
que on a un arsenal juridique
commençons par à comment dirais-je
utiliser arsenal juridique contre le
salafisme contre les frères musulmans le
que le communautarisme il faut je crois
ne tolérer aucune manifestation du
communautarisme
ni les heures différencier ni le reste
la burqa nous avons réglé son compte
mais je pense que on a affaire un islam
politique qui est en train d'essayer de
conquérir des territoires d esprit des
coeurs et il faut être absolument
intraitable sur l'ensemble de ces
manifestations
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que il faut prendre des mesures j'en ai
citer quelques unes mais il faut d'abord
être intransigeant est ferme sur nos
valeurs et encore une fois les faire
appliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'on tolère
des centaines de quartiers de banlieue
où les forces de l'ordre les pompiers
n'ose même plus entrer qui sont des
réserves de trafic de trafic d'armes de
trafic de stupéfiants
chaque jour et vous avez des collègues
du monde d'eau
collègues qui ont pris des exemples à
trappes et ailleurs eh bien tant qu' on
supportera ces territoires perdus de la
république nous ferons pour l'islamisme
radical
un terreau qui lui permettra de
continuer à frapper le coeur de la
france le procès on arrive t qui est
fait par laurent wauquiez notamment à
l'endroit du gouvernement et du chef de
l'état vous y souscrivent et je pense
qu'il est juste et je vous aide et des
deux exemples je n'aime pas comment
dirais-je asséné un certain nombre de
vérités sont les montrer je pense que
quand benjamin griveaux accuse des
intellectuels la plupart de haute volée
de stigmatisation c'est que il est sujet
à cet écran de fumée que les islamistes
envoie en disant dès lors que vous
critiquez cet islam radical et politique
alors vous êtes un islamophobe monsieur
griveaux tomber dans ce panneau
et lorsque j'ai indiquées et j'ai
critiqué les propos de monsieur castaner
dimanche dernier dans une émission de
radio je fais la même chose
bien sûr il y à cette naïveté il y à cet
angélisme je pense qu'aujourd'hui je me
tiens doute je pense une vraie
incertitude y compris sur le concept de
laïcité
vous attendez je pense de l'état
en tout cas cette incertitude se doute
fondamental que le chef de l'état donc
doit donc levé jeu qu'il doit lever
parce que ses principaux ministres porte
parle du gouvernement monsieur castaner
patron drm eux se sont avancés ce sera
le terrain là la question que je pose
c'est est-ce que ils ont exprimé la
pensée du président de la république si
tel était le cas alors oui on pourrait
la définir et la qualifier précisément
de naïve d'angélique en tout cas de
contraire à ce que souhaite je crois les
français pour leur sécurité
est ce qui nécessite aujourd'hui en
france en termes de mesures pour
protéger les français vous attendait une
réponse de l'exécutif est ce que vous
attendez aussi une prise de position de
l'islam de france ce qu'ils et elles
doivent bien sûr d'âge et au delà des
condamnations
mais bien sûr bien sûr moi je ne crois
pas que l'état puisse réformer de
l'extérieur l'islam
je pense que il faut que l'islam se
réforme
il faut qu'ils puissent expliquer
puisque malheureusement c'est au nom de
l'islam d'un islam évidemment des
voiliers que ces djihadistes que ces
terroristes porte le faire moi je pense
que et je les dis avec françois fillon
il ya longtemps il avait écrit un livre
on en avait beaucoup parlé il ya un peu
plus d'un an je pense qu'on a affaire au
troisième totalitarisme le totalitarisme
islamiste
il faut le dénoncer et donc avec l'islam
ce que je dis c'est que ce que je dis
très précisément c'est que ceux qui en
sont se réclament de l'islam donc l'état
l'islam parce que je sais parfaitement
ayant des amis qui sont musulmans je
sais parfaitement qu'il peut y avoir un
issam compatible avec les valeurs de la
république
mais quand l'institut montaigne
l'institut montaigne franchement fait
une étude est que selon cette étude 28 %
des musulmans considèrent que la charia
est supérieure aux lois de la république
alors on s'inquiète et je pense que
c'est d'abord aux musulmans de france à
faire ce travail de contextualisation de
l'islam et ce travail de tolérance en
réalité religieuse qui est aussi un
travail qui concerne la laïcité
républicaine
est ce que c'est une erreur d'avoir
supprimé l'état d'urgence qui permettait
certaines petre perquisition
administrative selon vous écoutez en
juin le sénat qui se présente comme le
camp défenseurs des libertés publiques
bien sûr moi j'ai voté le texte
j'ai voté le texte sur la sécurité
intérieure et et contre le terrorisme
il faudra expertiser les mesure où les
angles morts s'il y en a très
franchement je pense que ça n'est pas le
fond du problème
encore une fois j'ai indiqué un certain
nombre de pistes je pense qu'il faut
d'abord la lucidité le courage
d'appliquer les arsenaux que nous avons
à notre disposition par ailleurs donc
vous avez une approche un peu différente
de laurent wauquiez faisant passer mais
je vais marquer votre différence je vais
pas besoin de marquer je ne cherche pas
je n'ai pas besoin de marquer ma
différence j'ai c'est d'être utile à mon
pays et je dis que l'on sera utile avec
cette lucidité le courage il faut
réévaluer un certain nombre de réponses
justes
c est ce qu on a tourné la page taubira
en matière de laxisme judiciaire je n'en
suis pas sûr je n'en suis pas sûr c'est
pour ça que je propose cette histoire de
double peine
je pense que en termes de réponse
policière je pense pas que la police du
quotidien apporte quoi que ce soit et je
pense que le texte sur l'immigration
je pense que le texte sur l'immigration
de monsieur collomb sera totalement
insuffisant et qu'il ne changera rien
donc je propose aussi un certain nombre
de changements mais faisons déjà
appliqué dans toute la rigueur la loi de
la république dans des quartiers et dans
les esprits qu'il faut reconquérir par
l'école et l'affirmation de nos valeurs
c'est ce qu'a fait le colonel par
nouvelle train donc réarmement moral que
politique et idéologique absolue parce
que vous dites qu'elle sort faut-il
réservé à l'ancien candidat de la france
insoumise qui s'est distingué ce
week-end avec des tweets abjecte
concernant la mort de cet officier de
gendarmerie une source judiciaire
est ce que vous vous associez ce tweet
d'un don d'un ex-candidat de la france a
soumis ce qui n'est plus à la france
insoumise est ce que comme d'autres vous
associer ce tweet au mouvement la france
a souligné la condamner je vais essayer
d'être nuancée mouvement qui était mou
ça lui arrive d'en voir ma politique
bien d'abord j'ai vu le tweet de
monsieur mélenchon qui ceci samu
totalement qui condamne et je crois que
la france a soumises va avoir une action
bien contre ce monsieur là ce que je dis
par ailleurs sans viser la france
assouplisse c'est que il ya en france ce
que moi j'appelle un islam au gauchisme
voilà quand on a vu la discussion entre
monsieur plenel et le directeur de la
rédaction de charlie hebdo
monsieur ris je ne vais pas ici vous
faire cette confidence pour vous dire
que je ne suis pas un lecteur assidu de
charlie hebdo
mais franchement entre monsieur plenel
et sony slam au gauchisme et monsieur
rice qui a bien vu les catastrophes du
totalitarisme islamiste je choisis
évidemment charlie hebdo est ce que vous
savez par ailleurs que dans l'université
de lille 2 la pièce de charme a été
interdite qu'elle a failli être
interdite par un syndicat d'étudiants de
bouche dans l'université paris diderot
donc
je n'assimile pas si j'ose dire la
france a soumises à ce mouvement là mais
il ya en france une idéologie qui
considère que dès lors que vous dénoncez
l'islam radical
vous êtes un dangereux islamophobe et
bien il faut commencer par lutter contre
cela et d'ailleurs j'observe que manuel
valls
on a souvent fait les frais deuxième
partie deuxième question tout de suite
de l'épreuve de vérité et ses augustes à
le faire qui va vous poser cette
deuxième question dans quelques secondes
[Musique]
augustin monsieur retailleau quel autre
position est ce que vous comptez
incarner face à emmanuel macron il
poursuit les réformes
il maintient le cap la réforme de la
sncf par exemple on a un peu de mal à
comprendre la position de la droite
certains députés disent qu'ils vont la
voter d'autres non est-ce que vous au
sénat vous la vôtre et moi je pense
qu'elle va dans le bon sens et
j'appuierai une proposition de loi qui
va être présentée par un collègue
centriste est un ex collègue ait l'air
sur l'ouverture à la concurrence des
scènes cfg été la première région quand
j'étais président de région que j'ai été
la première région à faire délibérer
moan assemblées régionales constatant
les retards constatant que le système
était en train de s'effondrer ne
fonctionnait plus à faire voter donc par
une délibération cette idée d'ouverture
à la concurrence comme en allemagne à
plusieurs années sur des lignes
notamment régionales pour les univers
donc je souscris assez dit et là et
c'est une réforme qui va dans le bon
sens mais par ailleurs je pense que
toutes les réformes des mâles vaqueront
ne vont pas dans le bon sens
au contraire alors comment est ce que
vous allez définir votre position
c'était la question
je dis souvent je dis simplement quand
les choses vont dans le bon sens sur lui
quand elles ne vont pas dans le bon sens
je pense que mails macron cache sous une
frénésie de réformes sous une forme de
boulimie de réforme de trop petites
réformes
je vous en donner deux ou trois exemples
très rapidement
et vous pourrez le démentir si j'osais
je pars sous votre contrôle si vous le
souhaitez mais je l'attends avec
impatience un le gouvernement triomphe
en triomphe par ce que le déficit public
serait passé en 2017 à 2,6 en
conditionnelle serait passé il est passé
à part des trucs bien sûr bien sûr pour
les prélèvements mais écoutez moi les
prélèvements obligatoires donc les
impôts les taxes ont bondi de 0 8%
première chose si ça fait deuxième chose
deuxième chose c'est la croissance qui
vient d'ailleurs parce que notre corps
cette croissance elle est d'ailleurs
plus faible que en moyenne en europe et
on en a bénéficié
c'est le poids relatif qui exprime ce
ratio est enfin c'est surtout la la
dépense publique monsieur même macron a
fait moins bien en 2017
que monsieur hollande en 2016 en 2016
les dépenses publiques avec augmenté de
0,7 pour cent en 2017
les dépenses publiques ont augmenté
tenez vous bien de trois fois plus de
2,3 pour cent et d'ailleurs est
d'ailleurs la plupart dans la plupart
des pays européens de la zone euro la
moyenne c'est 0,9 la compétitivité des
entreprises
une nouvelle étude sort on est dernier
de la zone euro sur l'immigration j'en
parlais monsieur collomb va bomber le
torse et bilin son texte ne changera
rien donc ce sont des illusions de
réformes voyez sur des points aussi
fondamentaux que la dette et
l'endettement qui va continuer à croître
puisque pourquoi est-ce que
l'endettement crois mais le déficit ce
n'est pas une illusion ou des petites
est réellement en dessous de la barre
des 3 pour al oui mais exprimé par
rapport à une croissance la croissance
elle augmente partout dans le monde
pratiquement et donc c'est parce que la
croissance augmente que voilà est-ce que
dernier argument vous savez que la
contribution de la france à l'europe
elle a baissé de 4 milliards en 2017 et
c'est grâce à tous ces artifices
finalement aux impôts qui bondissent
malgré la dépense qui elle aussi
augmenter fortement avec la contribution
française européenne qui baisse c'est
comme cela que le gouvernement
là aussi vous montre ses muscles et
rebondissait aussi la croissance il ya
plus de ressort
il n'y avait pas un matraquage on n'est
plus
on a quand même inventer quand même
pratiquement huit axes la csg etc
alors certes ça va porter en 2018 mais
la réalité c'est quoi c'est que sur des
réformes qui sont vraiment extrêmement
important ce qu'on appelle le diviser
les déficits jumeaux
le déficit commercial abyssal le déficit
notamment avec les dépenses de l'état
budgétaire lui aussi très profond sur
ces deux points la caf emmanuel macron
rien compétitivité et dépenses publiques
rien et je pourrais allonger je parle
pas de la politique familiale qui
concède un qui continuent à massacrer
donc je veux dire que mon opposition
elle est réfléchie et quand les choses
au sénat j'ai voté sans doute plus de
textes que j'en ai refusé je n'ai pas
voté le budget évidemment après ce que
je viens de dire puisque toutes ces
éléments-là son contenu pour sauver le
service public de la sncf là vous
voterez je pense que cela va dans le bon
sens sur le service public c'est sur les
gars a mis fin tôt lecture sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence bien cela
va dans le bon sens mais attention il ya
les petites filles c'était on sera très
très attentif au sénat parce que nous
sommes la voix des territoires et moi je
sais bien que il ya des petites îles qui
sont importantes quand on veut aménager
le territoire
emmanuel macron ne doit pas que le
président uniquement des grandes villes
et des métropoles alors justement on a
un sondage comme chaque semaine pour
cette émission ans bruno retailleau nos
amis d'opinionway ont posé cette
question sur l'angle d'attaqué de la
droite justement sur la ruralité est ce
que emmanuel macron se préoccupe avant
tout des français vivant dans les
grandes agglomérations et bien 58% des
français sont d'accord avec cette
affirmation que vous
exprimé également ce soir un instant 3%
seulement pensent qu'il se préoccupe
avant tout de ce qui vit dans les zones
rurales et pour 36% en fait le chef de
l'état est neutre mais sur ce point je
vous propose d'écouter ce que déclaré
sur public sénat benjamin griveaux le
porte parole du gouvernement il vous
répond je prends les républicains ils ne
votent pas la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
c'est l'impôt le plus injuste pour les
territoires donc ils peuvent nous dire
la main sur le coeur les larmes aux yeux
qu'il s'occupe des territoires il ne
vote pas les crédits pour la création de
la police et de sécurité du quotidien ce
sont des policiers supplémentaires dans
les territoires il ne vote pas les
crédits pour les division par deux de
gamins dans les classes dans les
quartiers difficiles
c'est à nouveau pour les territoires en
difficulté donc je veux bien le faites
ce que je dis pas ce que je fais moi
j'en ai assez qu'ils fassent une
opposition constructive sérieuse
responsable et vous savez ce n'est pas
en antagonisent ans les français les uns
contre les autres les gens qui habitent
dans les villes il ne déteste pas les
gens qui habitent à la campagne et
inversement
bien au contraire alors voila voila et
oui vous renvoie dans leurs 22 mètres la
séance ordinaire s'il avait voulu me
donner les arguments il serait pas mieux
pris reprenons ses propres reproche il
nous dit d'abord l'école
nous avons montré que le dédoublement
des cas des classes à 12 élèves s'était
fait sur le dos des postes et des
fermetures de classes en milieu rural
j e division la relève et de la bien sûr
maintien les chiffres montrent linverse
premiers éléments
deuxième élément est nous dit la taxe
d'habitation ils veulent transférer aux
communes la taxe sur le foncier bâti et
la taxe sur le foncier bâti c'est les
mêmes bases donc il ya la même injustice
et ensuite c'est que les propriétaires
qui demain paieront que les
propriétaires comme par hasard les
retraités sont ceux qui sont le plus
propriétaire en france donc je leur
annonce un nouveau train de mesures et
vous verrez demain que il y aura sans
doute une augmentation du foncier bâti
par rapport à la taxe d'habitation
j'ai oublié le troisième son troisième
argument était pire je me souviens plus
que le lequel est excédé sur la police
de proximité
le territoire est extraordinaire c'est
peut-être pas la campagne c'est parce
que la campagne c'est les zones de
gendarmerie moi je j'habite là où je
suis né comme et 2007 sorte à peter j'ai
jamais vu un policier j'ai toujours vu
des gendarmes la réalité c'est une zone
gendarmerie est une zone qui n'est pas
une zone police donc benjamin griveaux
en trois exemples vient de nous
démontrer qu'ils ne comprend rien à la
réalité
moi je pense et j'étais encore une fois
prison de région je pense que la france
de demain c'est une bonne articulation
entre des métropoles des villes moyennes
et puis des petites communes la france
rurale
voilà mais je n'ai jamais opposées l'une
à l'autre simplement à vouloir une start
up nation
je pense qu'on en oublie ce qu'on
appelle la france périphérie de tous ces
territoires qui se sont oubliés qui se
sentent oubliés à la fois en matière de
mobilité de train mais aussi vous savez
de déserts médicaux en matière aussi de
mobilité hauteur en termes de téléphonie
mobile et je pense que c'est un résultat
d'ailleurs veut le sondage parle 3%
seulement des français considèrent
qu'ils aimaient macron est une voie pour
la réalité alors d'autres questions
maintenant d'autres réformes au
programme oui tu sionnel on connaît le
projet d'emmanuel macro institution
d'une dose de proportionnelle réduction
du nombre de parlementaires fin du cumul
des mandats dans le temps le sénat les
républicains y est opposée est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à dire au chef de l'état
allez-y on fait un référendum chiche
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas parce qu'on
connaît toujours le moment de la
question
on connaît jamais le contexte de la
réponse mais là encore une révision
constitutionnelle on doit en voir le
sens quel est le sens de cette révision
le sens de cette révision c'est de
donner encore plus de pouvoir emmanuel
macron pourquoi il veut abaisser le
parlement y a pas que moi qui le dit
pratiquement tous les mouvements
politiques en dehors dans marche mais
ils vont s'en apercevoir et encore y est
quand même les voix dissidentes jeu
l'observent pour la première fois donc
il veut abaisser le parlement est ce que
sous la vème république le parlement est
tout puissant
non c'est l'hyper président qui est tout
puissant
affaiblir les je pense que c'est une
tentative de tout puissant je pense que
il ya une forme du bri je pense quand on
est à l'elysée en tout cas c'est son cas
lui lui veut réduire à la fois
l'opposition parlementaire en abaissant
le parlement et il veut réduire en même
temps les territoires là encore cette
révision constitutionnelle si elle
allait à son terme en termes de baisse
du nombre
nous on n'est pas opposé contre la
baisse à la baisse du nombre des
parlementaires
mais à un moment donné cette base et
parlementaires ne permettra plus à la
représentation des territoires notamment
ruraux ou alors de la france
périphérique d'être si j'ose dire
entendu il faut des députés et des
sénateurs qui défendent ces territoires
et là encore je pense que la région
concessionnels elle confirme deux choses
elle confirme finalement qu' il est en
recherche d'une toute puissance du
césarisme c'est un trait de caractère à
combas et jupiter c'est comme voilà
c'est que il cherche à être dominateur
bien sûr bien sûr il a cherché à être là
telle opposition
son cv son rêve c'est quoi son rêve
c'est une grande force centrale au
tournant marche des oppositions
radicales qui rendra finalement toute
alternance impossible c'est ça son rêve
sur la réforme constitutionnelle sera
question de l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle qu'on voit de grandes
divergences entre la droite entre des
centristes on a parlé d' entre 10 et 25%
ou est-ce que vous placez le curseur
acceptable ce qui me choque sur la
question d'un proportionnelle c'est que
ça n'est pas un sur un mode de scrutin
qui soit de façon active si j'ose dire
fortement compatible avec les accessions
d'acier prêts publics et surtout c'est
un marchandage entre monsieur berrou -ml
macro
je suis de ceux je suis de ceux qui l'a
révélé f1 qu'il indiquait dans les
critiques que je fais sur la vision un
des premiers à l'avoir fermé c'est une
fin le 22 février 2017
l'accord entre monsieur macron pour
avoir les suffrages de monsieur bayrou
il se fait notamment sur une dose de
proportionnelle pourquoi parce que
monsieur bayrou l'a toujours dit dès
lors qu'il ya une proportionnelle
il installe le modem et le centre
justement au centre de la vie politique
française
quand se disant de droite et de gauche
on arrivera à faire basculer ça c'est le
retour
à la 5 à la quatrième république alors
vous dites quoi la dose vous c'est zéro
la dose c'est le moins possible c'est le
mieux ah oui mais comme vous êtes prêts
je pensais gérer non je pense que pour
cent des parts je perds je pense que la
proportionnelle je pense que l'acompte
porte n'est pas compatible avec les
institutions dans un cabanon et jeudi
que regardons l'allemagne 5 mois pour
établir un gouvernement regardant
l'italie et d'autres pays pour se rendre
compte de l'effet nocif de la
proportionnelle parce que ce que je
crains c'est que dès lors qu'on aura un
stylet dans le coeur des institutions ce
principe proportionnelle bien il aura
comme tous les principes pour mécanisme
de se dilater progressivement alors vous
êtes proche du président du sénat alors
si vous êtes parfaitement en phase sur
ces questions là avec lui bien
évidemment
est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut quand
même se dégager un consensus entre
gérard larcher et emmanuel macron sur
ces questions institutionnelles
moi je pense que contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu dire la vraie ligne rouge
le cumul moi je préfère évidemment
laisser la liberté aux français de
choisir leurs élus dans ce genre je suis
un mandat ça peut être trop bon mais je
ne sais pas la vraie ligne rouge
la vraie ligne rouge pour nous c'est que
les territoires soient représente
d'accord avec un territoire soit
représentée à cette combien de sénateurs
par département au minimum que les
départements les plus pauvres en
démographie soit correctement
représentés
j'attire votre attention distorsion de
démographie une distorsion de
représentativité oui mais quand la
scénariste y avoir non je m'explique
vous avez raison on peut très bien
penser qu'une assemblée soit construite
sur un mode électoral différent elle
l'est actuellement
oui et que l'assemblée et pour fonction
de représenter une population et que les
saunas le sénat et pour fonction de
représenter sans doute une population
mais en même temps des territoires
regardez les états unis le plus grand
état à deux représentants au sénat est
le plus petit 2 alors c'est un état
fédéral et nous ne le sommes pas mais
entre les américains et ce que manuel
macron veut faire il ya une mesure et
cette mesure là je pense que elle
nécessite que les territoires les plus
faibles en population puisse être alors
gérard larcher nous parler
et parle régulièrement de plusieurs
lignes rouges vous dit en fait il y en a
qu'une donc je repose ma question est ce
que vous pensez qu effectivement un
terrain d'entente pourrait être trouvé
avec le chef de l'état on vous sent
plutôt optimiste ah non je suis plein à
leur plaît plutôt bien mais l'ex alors
je suis perplexe parce qu'il ya il ya un
certain nombre de sujets
l'affaiblissement du du parlement avec
le droit d'amendement avec ledroit
d'armement l'ordre du jour et caetera et
caetera avec la représentation du
territoire avec la question de la
proportionnelle on a là trois sujets qui
sont des sujets très très lourd ou
emmanuel macron fait un pas donne sa
chance au dialogue et écoute ce que lui
dit le parlement est sur nos positions
parce que la révision constitutionnelle
ça peut pas seulement être en marche il
faut que ce soit plus large qu'en marche
donc s'il veut aboutir aux trois
cinquièmes au congrès cette majorité qui
est impensable pour réviser le droit
d'amendement c'est aussi une ligne rouge
l'affaiblissement du parlement ces
tendances troisième partie tout de suite
de l'épreuve de vérité avec la question
que va vous poser
paulo bria
[Musique]
forces républicaines que vous présidez a
tenu une convention samedi sur sur
l'europe
on ya entendu des positions divergentes
au sein de de la droite alors est ce que
les républicains ont une ligne sur
l'europe
et si oui laquelle moi je souhaite qu'on
ait une ligne
il faut qu'on ait une ligne vous savez
que emmanuel macron il n'a pas caché à
plusieurs reprises notamment à la
sorbonne mails macron ne se cache pas il
souhaite lui profiter des européennes
pour casser un peu plus à droite donc il
faut pas qu'on tombe dans le panneau
il faut pas qu'on ait une europe
honteuse donc il faut assumer parce que
je pense qu'on a besoin d'europe
pourquoi est ce qu'on a besoin d'europe
tout simplement parce que le monde est
plus menaçant que jamais et on voit
ressurgir des vieux empire l' empire
ottoman avec la turquie
l' empire russe avec poutine si jean
ping an près ravis avec la chine et même
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'autres
nations continentales si j'ose dire donc
face à ce monde menaçant et au retour
justement de ces deux de ses étapes et
de ces empires la réponse continentale
elle est européenne
pas n'importe quelle europe pourquoi
parce que l'europe n'a jamais été autant
au bord du précipice
je pense qu'un énorme paradoxe jamais
les pays européens n'ont été aussi
proches dans leur histoire et en même
temps jamais l'union européenne n'a été
aussi proches près d'une éventuelle
dislocation pourquoi les peuples
vous avez eu une bride sites excite les
français les anglais on dit on part mais
vous avez vu beaucoup d'autres
insurrections électorale en italie en
autriche et même en allemagne où la
première force d'opposition désormais
c'est l'afd si l'extrême droite en
allemagne vous rendez compte donc
et quand on écoute au moment de ces
élections les uns les autres on voit que
les peuples ne veulent plus d'une europe
qui se fasse sans eux je pense qu'il
faut réinstaller l'europe d'un processus
démocratique avec un projet que nous
allons nous élaborer une trentaine de
propositions qui tombe dehors qui
tourneront autour de trois chapitres le
premier c'est l'ordre des peuples une
europe des peuples en s'appuyant par
exemple sur la subsidiarité
on veut pas l'europe de l'accessoire
tatillonne l'europe de la réglementation
une europe de l'essentiel sur un sérum
de sujets une europe qui soient fiers
des valeurs l'europe est un projet de
civilisation et je pense que ça c'est
fondamental
l'europe n'est pas un projet
institutionnel fédéral c'est d'abord on
doit être fiers de la civilisation lors
des peuples l'europe ensuite de la
protection l'europe doit assumer des
frontières les défendre or l'europe
s'est souvent bâtis contre cette idée de
frontières on n'a pas su si j'ose dire
où étaient nos limites
eh bien nous proposons une robe vraiment
européenne comme disait le général de
gaulle sans la turquie au moment où je
vous parle monsieur erdogan par en
bulgarie pour discuter avec monsieur
lucas est bien s'énonce eni vérifier qu
est-ce que l'adhésion pour la turquie
est un objectif stratégique il faut dire
non à la turquie aujourd'hui parce que
on le doit au peuple turc hommes aux
peuples européens
la turquie c'est 95% de son sol qui est
asiatique et idem il faut stabiliser nos
frontières entre la mer baltique et la
mer egée ça veut dire pas de partenariat
oriental est ce que vous avez envie que
demain plats des lasers badjan rentrer
dans l'union européenne
évidemment non y compris pour un
oratoire ce qui est de renvoyer
certaines grandes nations comme la
turquie justement vers l'asie mais
c'était l'argument que l'on entend mais
on m'a forcément je la vois on peut
attendre désormais oui d'accord peut
avoir des accords le depuis 95 la
turquie dans une union douanière donc on
peut avoir des accords bien mais il faut
dire ce que l'europe est et ce qu'elle
n'est pas par exemple le reverra
asiatique prônée par le chef de l'état
qu'en dites vous eh bien non moi je dis
un moratoire sur les pays des balkans
voilà parce que notre capacité
d'absorption elle n'en peut plus elle
est absolument saturé donc une europe
des peuples avec une idée on tourne le
dos à la tate grassi et eneurope
vraiment démocratique avec kiss qui
assume d'être une civilisation son
histoire sa géographie concrètement
quelqu'un promet une robe d'amour
d'action accru démarre à 10 ans leur
exemple a pu par exemple sur l'impreza
non non non par exemple un carton rouge
donné au parlement européen au parlement
français mais aussi aux parlements
nationaux c'est à dire que à partir du
moment où 55% des parlements nationaux
disent non à une initiative de la
commission européenne qui violerait
le principe de subsidiarité droit de
veto département way un droit de veto ah
oui mais à 55 % peuvent discuter d'une
majorité
ça c'est un exemple mais pas d'europe
fédérale l'europe des manuels de mâcon
c'est quoi en réalité c'est une europe
du fédéralisme il veut il voulait
démissionner manger pour tout de suite
un phénomène est d'ailleurs innommable
il a réclamé des listes transnationales
une échec
il a réclamé un parlement de la zone
euro échec
il a réclamé aussi un ministre des
finances de la zone euro échec un budget
de la zone euro échec pour l'instant il
est seul notre europe
l'ordre des peuples de la protection les
frontières protection commerciale
on n'a pas je veux dire on est la zone
on est la zone économique la plus
ouverte au monde
il faut faire ce que d'autres font c'est
à dire le principe du juste échange de
la réciprocité
le principe de la protection de nos
propres intérêts une robe de la défense
sans doute avec le royaume-uni puisque
le royaume uni c'est pratiquement un
tiers dans une alliance de défense
européenne avec des programmes communs
en matière d'armement et puis ensuite il
faudra une robe des projets c'est à dire
que une autre beaucoup plus offensive
qui redeviennent le continent de
l'intelligence de la connaissance de la
recherche et l'innovation mais sur
quelques sujets stratégiques et précis
comme l'énergie comme le numérique comme
l'intelligence artificielle alors vous
dites que le projet du chef de l'état
parallèlement pour les élections
européennes c2 avec son projet de bloc
central c'est de casser un peu plus la
droite 1 qui est divisée sur le sujet on
sait il ya quand même des personnalités
éminentes dans votre camp bruno
retailleau qui se sont assez proches des
manuels macron sur les questions
européennes
et c'est notamment le cas d'alain juppé
il ya un moment important pour moi c'est
l'europe je ne cautionnerai en aucune
manière un discours anti européen
[Musique]
quelle qu'en soit la virulence de rang
pour l'instant il n'y a pas beaucoup de
déclarations en ce sens j'ai dit que je
me reconnaissais assez bien dans le
discours que le président de la
république a prononcé la sorbonne à la
fin de l'année dernière sur l'europe
je suis exactement où à peu près
exactement sur cette ligne toute la
question est de savoir maintenant si
monsieur macron a les moyens de mettre
en oeuvre des idées qui va avancer
vous savez très bien que ça ça va
dépendre de chant dialogue avec un gala
bercail sur ce sujet vous reconnaissez
plus dans le discours d' emmanuel macron
que nancy laurent wauquiez c'est ça
certainement alain juppé se reconnaît
plus dans le discours d' emmanuel macron
sur l'europe que dans celui de laurent
wauquiez et vous c'est le contraire vous
reconnaissez plus dans le discours de
laurent wauquiez
très contesté sur cette thématique là
non moi je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
formes d'europe possible il ya l'europe
de leur vaut de pardon des mails macron
kate une europe qu'armand fédéral mais
c'est en europe c'est l'ordre de
l'impossible ces lampes chimère parce
que les autres européens n'en veulent
pas je vous ai pris quatre exemples
alors et celle de leurs enfants
et puis il ya l'autre robe de conte est
bien marine le pen aussi qu'elle en
boucs émissaires donc il ya d'un côté
l'europe des élites et l'autre côté
l'europe qui se délite avec une
éventuelle sortie de l'euro donc moi je
pense qu'on va incarner l'europe des
possibles avec cette idée d'une europe
non pas contre atik parce que l'europe
fédérale
c'est une europe qui se fait à l'abri
des peuples les peuples n'en veulent pas
donc pour faire une europe fédérale il
faut le faire à l'écart des peuples et
il faut le faire avec une discipline de
fer avec la production de normes de
contraintes toujours plus importants
vous l'avez entendu je pense qu'ils
feront qu il faut il a toujours sa place
à condition bien sûr que oui
mais alain juppé dit mais à condition
d'accord monsieur legrand soit entendu
par les partenaires européens et les
partenaires européens ils lui ont
répondu il ya eu un conseil avec madame
merkel jeudi et vendredi dernier il ya
eu huit pays d'europe du nord avec à sa
tête le premier ministre hollandais
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit à monsieur
emmanuel macron ils ont dit non on ne
veut pas cette voie là non la voie
raisonnable c'est la voie que nous
allons proposer une europe démocratique
une europe qui va se protéger enfin des
flux migratoires qui se protégera en
matière économique et en matière de
défense et enfin une europe qui se
défend si vos six qui assume une marche
en avant sur des projets
certainement pas une europe fédérale on
va pas augmenter les difficultés de
l'europe parce que les peuples n'en
veulent plus comme cela
augustin dans les puissances que vous
avez cités tout à l'heure comme des
menaces pour l'europe on a on a évoqué
la turquie vous avez aussi parlé de la
russie aujourd'hui il ya eu des
expulsions d'espions dans toute l'europe
et en amérique du nord
est ce que c'est la bonne réponse à ce
pays récemment montré qu'en réseau là
encore moi j'ai une position qui est
très très nuancée autant je pense qu'on
a bien fait d'être solidaire de du
royaume uni parce que je pense que cette
solidarité là elle est essentielle elle
a continué essentielle
demain si on veut une alliance de
défense européenne il y aura pas de
défense européenne si le royaume uni ne
coopère pas avec nous parce que c'est le
seul qui ait une vision globale
stratégie en arrivant sur la russie il
ne faut pas non plus la culée et on a
bien vu que les américains qui l'ont
encerclé avec la politique
d'élargissement de l'otan d'un certain
nombre de bases militaires
le fait aussi que on est incertain
nombreux à certains moments violé un
certain nombre de décisions de l'onu est
rendu notre partenaire russe extrêmement
méfiant donc je dis qu'il faut être
ferme quand la russie franchi un son de
frontières au sens propre et figuré mais
en même temps il faut surtout pas
pousser la russie et la considérer si
j'ose dire comme un adversaire
je pense qu'on a besoin d'une relation
avec la russie qui a eu une histoire qui
est en train de se sortir d'une histoire
du communisme qui a vu sa fierté
rabaisser du temps de monsieur elstine
qui est à la recherche de cette fierté
nationale donc attention à ne pas trop
blessée l'ours
même si fois le ton juste et dire nos
désaccords quand il y à vraiment d
accord qu est ce que vous avez pensé de
l'abandon par l'occident des kurdes
justement lamentable bombe absolument
lamentable triple erreur grosse et alors
grosse erreur j'étais malheureusement
enfin d'autres un peu ont protesté
triple erreur une erreur d'abord
humanitaire parce que c'est le nettoyage
ethnique nettoyage ethnique une erreur
politique
on a permis à des djihadistes allié à
bachar al assad de se réimplanter
l'armée libres 2
irina rien de libre et elle est composée
pour une grande partie de mouvements qui
sont des mouvements extrémistes donc
finalement par rapport à ce qui se passe
chez nous on a fermé les yeux là dessus
on le paiera malheureusement et enfin
une erreur diplomatique parce que on a
eu besoin des kurdes comme chair à canon
en face des djihadistes et au moment où
ils ont besoin de nous on a dit on n'est
plus là c'est terrible c'est indiqué à
tous nos alliés que aux moments graves
ont fait défection mais je sais que vous
décrivez je suis bien sûr un déshonneur
le mot est important mais en tout cas je
suis sévère sur cet abandon parce que je
pense que cet abandon ne servira pas les
intérêts notamment français à moyen
terme pour nos matériaux merci d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui merci
messieurs bonsoir à tous et à très vite
[Musique]
m